citizens of the reject Nation hello my name's
Aaron who we have here we got Andrew here Havey
Aaron we got one Andrew Gordon here we're
here to watch A Million Ways to Die in the
West that's why I'm talking here in this old uh
accent as they like to say I've never seen this
movie but I know I know it's about uh one Mr
Seth Rogan nope Seth marar that's the guy he
knows the stuff about the movies you guys leave
a comment about this dang movie if you like it
if you seen it we're going to go and embark on
this whole dang thing like subscribe hit that
notification Bell because Tara isn't here she
is healing up so send your comments down below
because we miss her we love her and we will
see her return to sing that Bell song as she
does so well ring that [Music] bell ring the
bell full life reactions over on the patreon
where you sync up with your own dang copy so
you can watch it with us Us in real time like
we're old buddies like we're old Pals guys John
and Greg covers several things exclusively over
there a lot of movies a lot of shows you're going
to love it you're going to have a great old time
all right you ready to watch million days Dy in
the west let's do it all right then [Applause]
Yeehaw Andrew you're a connoisseur in
westerns have you seen a lot of them uh
not too many the but I would say my favorite
Western is Back to the Future Part three how
about you D Jango and janed I I have not not
seen Jango I've not seen very many Quinton
Tarantino films at [Music] all we're already
getting that Western feel I like it now wonder
what's like the line between being a genuine
Western and being a parody As we watch this
well I mean I've only seen Ted and I've
watched Family Guy but obviously Seth
McFarland loves runchy comedy so he also
loves his comedy cutaways a staple of that
man ah we got a couple returning
cast members from Ted Patrick Harris
okay Sarah Silverman surprisingly doesn't
seem like an odd choice to be in this movie
but Liam n I'm shocked West stud oh wow who's
that uh well he was sagot and Street Fighter I
if you saw that he was also in uh Last of the
Mohicans uh he seen so many different movies
I understand this is an homage to how movies
used to do it back in the day but I'm happy
they don't do this anymore could you imagine
sitting through credits in the theater for
like 6 minutes yeah some people are born into
the wrong time and place this was the American
frontier in 1882 a hard land for hard folk food
was scarce disease was rampant and life was a
daily struggle for survival damn hell this was
Miss America in 1880 holy [__] to build a home
and a life in this harsh unforgiving country
required that a man be bold and tough as iron
The Men Who were courageous and resilient were
The Men Who prospered but some men were just big
giant surprised you showed up Stark yeah well you
said you'd kill my family and burn my house down
if I didn't so is there anything at all that I can
say to get you to call this off you yellow Stark
well that's a little racist to our hardworking
friends over here from the Far East right
guys the fake stashes talk this out you know
we can find a calm rational solution maybe
we even laugh about it one day you know
I ain't in the mood to laugh oh hey look
this will make you laugh look at our shadows
looks like our shadows are about to kiss each
other oh my God Charlie oh my God thank you so
this is so generous of you look we're laughing
right we're laughing now what what were we
even fighting about I I can't remember can
you oh I'll pay you the money you lost Just
Give Me 2 days to sell off a few of my sheep
I don't have that cash I'm coming after
you what a relief for all these people
who came out here hoping that we would find an
amicable solution to this huh somebody shoot
some point out that guy's an English
teacher at our school oh my God just
a little taste just a little taste just a
little taste I like the balance between the
serus and the like the parody yeah no
it's funny I mean I tell him I'll pay
him off we go our separate ways and
that's it but no he shoots me in the
leg you should have fought him I should have
fought him she's like yeah you really are
the guy is one of the best shots around
I look like I have Parkinson's next to
him what is that it's just another way God m
mysteriously shows that he loves us but look
look that Albert I'm breaking up with you of
course as I talk about Back to the Future Part
three why don't you just tell me what the problem
is and then maybe I can fix it maybe if I were
older the timing would be right but people are
living to be 35 these days a girl doesn't have
to just go off and get married right away I have
to work on myself oh my God you did not just say
that I have to work on myself Louise that's
the oldest line in the book you realize that
yep it's not you it's me right I love you I'm
sorry maybe when he becomes as somebody she'll
come back yes come on come on someone's getting
to Ean you don't you I do it's really [Laughter]
terrific oh another Ted uh oh and Family
Guy yeah it's Lois I thought I'd take her
out for picnic it sounds like she's just
about done up there oh poor guy all over
my oh Jesus you're okay with your girlfriends
15 different guys every day and getting paid to
do it oh my job sucks too that's how we
make a living well I got off work early
and I thought we could go for a walk by the
stream oh oh yeah no no I had to give um so
wait to kiss me get get some mouthwash don't
I have the best boyfriend Millie honestly I
I have no [__] [Music] idea there's nothing
wrong with breath Andrew that's a true sign of
love how didn't you even get up there goats
can climb right I don't know about goats but
not sheep yeah I don't know about
sheep hey guys guys we heard about
Louise I that's horrible do you you want
to sit down I'm good I'm going to rest my
[__] just looking at these old pictures of
me and Louise this is from the carnival M oh
yeah look like a happy Cup this is the squirt
why did they do that back then have you ever
smiled in a photograph no have you oh God
no no you looked like an insane person but
right that's what I'm saying n dude keep that
Stone Face up I say that cuz I suck at smiling
so she was the one thing that made the shootings
and the diseases and the wild animals and the
Indians and the general depressing awfulness
about the West beable I didn't realize how
tall he was yeah let's get up that's the answer
to everyone's problems the age old tradition
forget your troubles let's kill our livers
what is there to live for on the frontier
in 1882 the American West is a disgusting
awful dirty dangerous place look around you
everything out here that's not you wants to
kill you Outlaws angry drunk people scorned
workers hungry animals you you can get killed
just going to the bathroom there rattlesnakes
all in the grass out there and and even if I
make it you know what can kill me Coler up the
black the black even if you survive all those
things you know what else can kill you theing
Doctor oh you need an ear nail a nail in my
ear that is modern medicine for you do I have
a fever of 102 oh you need a donkey kicking
constipation cramps dyspepsia liver disease
kidney disease hemorrhoids it's like the smartest
guy ever in 1882 literally die from their own
farts that is our mayor he is dead he
has been lying there dead for 3 Days
the highest ranking official in our town
has been a dead guy oh look at that look
at that as if to illustrate my point
bye bye Mr Mayor bye have fun becoming
wolf I want to live in the American West cess
pool of Despair and all of it why don't you
shut up you shut up ow I don't know maybe
you should TR to talk to Louise that's a
great idea yeah that's the jackpot still got
it okay there it is good idea so I didn't mean
now oh cuz talking to your ex while you're
drunk is always a great idea oh I'm excited
to see him ride a horse tr you're going to
get exactly what you want oh God here we
go surpris he didn't fall was taking a lot of
rehearsal for that bet she has new man already
probably yeah maybe it's Neil Patrick Harris
maybe it's Liam n oh yeah could be that to hey
hey Albert what the hell are you doing Lise we
need to talk Lise please listen to me I love you
okay I'm sure you're right for somebody else just
not for me wait let me just touch [Laughter] you
I heard you fart once and it went it was a
sharp one Shar little Sharpie poop toot and I
heard I really did think she was going to
have a guy there but yeah same come on boy hey
down we'll be taking that gold off you
howy folks how oh there he is what can
I do for you fellas we're riding through
to Sherman Creek we obliged you could tell
tell us the shortest route Willam n hey I
can help you with that I got a map right
here uh clearly want your gold sir I I'd
take Bill be pass safer too less chance
of Bandits and such uh one more thing
you might do for us you show us the
gold I ain't got no gold I wish old plugger and
I done give it up we're going on back into town
you're heading back to town in the middle of the
day a prospector only does that when he's found
gold to sell o going into town to get I might
just have a little bit of gold here take it
pick up your gun well I'm not just going to take
your gold that'll be stealing oh no bye-bye Mr
prospector H we sh on three oh man one a two
wow he's a cheater H clinch you didn't have
to shoot him clinch no I didn't have to
sweetart he would have given you the gold
point is I had to ask him twice you're a son
of a [__] is what you were don't you ever
say that to me in front of my man man's
wife will respect him oh oh my God I love
you I'm like the luckiest girl ever in the H
very convincing was not expecting them to be
married leis you take Anna and right East and
hole up here in the old stump a take that dog
yet she going to pet that dog she going to
keep that dog that does suck for that old
guy guess the lesson here is don't lie
to Liam n well look who's up at two in
the afternoon get your life taken we literally
just had a conversation about waking up at 2:
in the afternoon before we started
shooting I'm going to use the out
housee if I die out there will you guys
just do me one favor I want you to switch
seats he going to say eras my search history
your Western search history yeah Albert you
look terrible oh wow there's that conf thanks a
lot how you doing buddy I'll take it it's days
of past at this point oh I haven't seen you in
town in a week and a half oh okay there we go
I just feel like I need to stay here with
my parents they're not going to be around
much longer to give back all the love and
affection that I got growing up right guys
ow I love him so
much you got to get out of this fun I mean you
haven't Shor your sheep in [Music] weeks Oh no
you're going home every night to your girlfriend
who loves you you're having sex with her uh no
Ruth and I have what damn everyone else gets
to do that with her but you right that's wild
no Ruth wants to wait till we get married she
a Christian and so am I and boy they have an
interesting relation have you ever had with anyone
well there was some [__] with my uncle but that
was oh what no oh my God this got dark really
quickly I'll get out I'll meet some people yeah
thanks okay came out of my P yeah that should
have made me laugh that was dumb me personally
I'm over fart jokes um I Dumb and Dumber did it
perfectly and then yeah it's been done to death
after that Ed look look oh no you're right you
called it hey NE Patrick Harris he's irresistible
she told me she didn't want to see anybody
she told me she had to work on herself look
at that Foy the owner of the mustachery oh look
at that he's kissing her us men with mustaches
were irresistible I can't afford it the creams the
waxes the lotions I don't have the money it's true
it is expensive to have a mustache oh hey look
it's the ice and itchy uhoh that's going to land
on somebody it's so neat I know it's actually
really interesting how they do it is this one
company out in Boston had to get a bason reference
in for Seth mcfallen and ponds and they just
[Applause] ship that went South so fast
Jesus oh jeez no more shall they nibble
wantedly at the teeth of our coffers I we
also like to offer a heartfelt prayer to
the family of James Addison I thought I was
going to land on somebody like entirely not
somebody's face yeah yeah yeah James we will
think of you lovingly this July As We Sip the
cold summer beverages for which you gave
your life they're still going to use the
ice Lewis Barnes and his sister Anna they've just
moved here to old stump and they planed to build a
farm well that concludes today's service so may
God bless you for another week and there is a
mountain line warning in effect oh wow a mountain
line warning in effect I'm the mustachery that's
awesome you love it there Andrew oh I I would so
go there I was thinking that we could go dress
shopping later I was thinking you need a new dress
something expensive stupidly expensive yeah yeah
you think she's going to become jealous when she
sees chariss thone with Seth what's up kiddo never
seen you in here before it's just browsing you
don't have a mustache though I might get one I
said I was thinking about growing one like one
of those ones that goes down along the side of
my mouth the edge of my jaw and then becomes my
sideburns a Mobius mustache mobus mustache that's
the one you should know that kind of mustache is a
very costly facial accessory you're a sheep farmer
know your place stealing a guy's girlfriend that's
what you're doing you feel good about that hey
Louise dumped you my friend it's not my fault she
wanted someone with more to offer oo I can give
her a lavish home warm blankets wrapped candies
and a mustache you know you man yeah that's what
she's doing oh damn he's got some good comebacks
he's smooth with it NPH don't miss even in 1882 he
NPH don't miss n pH don't miss oh hey sweetie hi
hi Mark hey Ed W what a long day poor guy got to
earn a living what do you think about us spending
the night together but Eddie we're Christians and
I want to do the correct thing in the eyes of the
Lord but if we really do love each other don't you
think God would be okay with him you're talking
about premarital relations oh oh God damn it
oopsy yuck yeah that's going to leave a mark
I'm done I'm leaving I'm going to San Francisco
I don't know how I lasted this long I hate the
frontier I hate everything in it well what am
I going to do I'm your best friend that's why
I want you to have these it's like w is still
a teddy bear Albert these are your favorite
socks yeah and I want you to have that you're
gross Edward this is your lucky handkerchief not
lucky anymore well hello to you [Laughter] yeah
oh God blow your own horse hey watch it pal I
think you owe me a drink B you best watch where
you stand I'm thirsty why don't you go on down
the river and take a dunk could be wrong but I
believe this actor was in 8 Mile one of Eminem's
friends also never seen a m ah be a good watch for
you my yeah Curtis Hansen did that one oh wow
definitely going to make it tastier you going
to kill you quicker than I thought quicker
than I imagined woo hey ah Albert hurry get
in position damn oh yeah we're both getting
hurt pretty badly that's smart of them that's
smart to do this fight is way more violent than
yours looks like they're doing Rock them sockum
oh I love how unfaced she looks oh oh that was
actually going to hit him so sorry you I put a
new move in there you don't just put a new move
in you that's why we have the meeting that's why
we have the meetings it wouldn't be a western
without a bar fight oh wow wow wow wow wow wow
wow love [Music]
interest [__] come on are you keeping count
of all the ways to die in the west have we had
a million yet I think we have we're close
we had a whole scene laying out all of them
yeah we've seen ice we've seen stabbings farting
stained handkerchiefs who this this is plugger
hey plugger that was your brother in there huh
yeah leis he's always been a little rambunctious
I'm I'm uh Albert by the way Welcome to our
awesome Town thanks this is how you get over
someone Aaron that's how you get over someone
getting under someone we were wanting a change
so we came out to the frontier looking to build a
farm oh that's what I do cattle uh no sheep well
that's got to be fulfilling work though hey
it's like being a dog walker for 150 really
stupid dogs oh [__] Jesus what is that it's
the mayor it's the mayor oh so how did you guys
meet she moved to town a couple years ago to
take over the school marm job our old school
marm got her throat spped by a fast moving tumble
weed in front of the kids oh yeah let me help you
we were together I just remember thinking how
can I possibly be this happy she likes me now
but one day she's going to figure out that
she's too good for me it sounds like you've
been over backwards for this girl but what has
she giv you back I told you she allowed me to
be happy allowed that's kind ofed up that you
would use that word you know that right this
Foy guy is that much of a douche she'll figure it
out if she's smart solid advice sometimes a girl
has to get a few [__] out of her system
before she realizes what a good guy looks
like it's actually my first cigarette ever
definitely a cigarette it looks like tobac
[Music] rattlesnake oh diamond back just it's okay
just hold perfectly still and it'll go away okay
okay now I'm nervous I'm not even in the movie
isn't the fair on Saturday Lise is going to be
there and she's going to be with FY I'm going
to put myself in inauguration I'll go with you
no better way than make your ex go from what you
backck more than to let her see with another girl
exactly too bad she's going to end up with
Liam niss in the end totally she's totally
going to stay with her husband and not leave
him for Seth McFarland you shot the pastor's
son you realize they're probably going to hang
you for this who gives up what they want when
clinch gets into town it's not going to matter
what they do why' you guys split off oh he went
to sell the gold right would he do that in town
where they are there's going to be a man who's
faster than clinch and then clinch is going to
be the dead man and I'm going to smoke a cigar
to celebrate I don't think clinch would like
you talking about him that way so what she's
saying is she's obsessively in love with
him let's see if he gets here before you
find yourself at the end of a rope who was just
thinking that what's the timetable and when he's
going to probably get hung I feel like it's
usually a week I don't know that for a fact
I just think that's sounds like an estimated
good time I feel the pastor's son they would
maybe expedited but we shall see oh no no no
no no no no guys no no no Andrew Jonathan no
Andrew [Music] yeah I've never seen it
separated like that in two words photo
photogaphs don't you freaking smile looks
like looks like a prison photo like a mug
shot supposedly there's some guy in Texas
who smiled one time while he was getting
his picture taken that we were just talking
about that last week is that true no I mean
I heard it somewhere I don't know
if it's true everybody hold still
holy [__] what the hell holy [__] that's
another du that's another way to die God this
Fair ladies and gentlemen step right up step
right up try a sample of Sir oh my god do you
recognize this actor oh it looks so familiar
Saved by the Bell the principal that's right
Ogden's celebrated stomach bitters can I just
ask celebrated by who look at the ingredients
alcohol morphine oh I want to try that so
badly Mercury with I need it science and
red red flannel there's shirt Red Flannel pieces
of shirt it gives it a little kick right Mak it
feel like a lumberjack that's them right uh uh
quick Let's uh pretend you just said something
funny to oh my God you are you are just introduce
me I'm not going I'm not going to introduce oh uh
this is Anna she's I'm his girlfriend she's my
girlfriend she's the new GF new GF Big Time lot
of sexual activity I live inside her so if you
want to send me a letter you got to address it
care of her type of relationship we all aspire
to have I have that skirt yep oh you do yeah I
wore it to the fair like two years ago but good
for you for trying to bring bring it back well
I figure only a complete idiot would throw
away a perfectly good thing we were going to
go check out the shooting gallery over there
you guys want to join what oh yes and let's
make things interesting a nickel a Target can you
afford that uh how about a penny what's a matter
Albert is business bad I understood that joke I
get it good Lord Albert you're such a sheep skate
oh they're so dumb that they're actually funny oh
wow that seems unnecessary what's
wrong with like ducks or oh my god
really okay there you go ma'am thank you
baby care to try it's like yes I played
at my local 7-Eleven I got this m
seems you owe me 6 cents wait hang on a sec you
want to make this interesting if I can shoot six
out of six on Albert's behalf you owe him a
dollar ooh a dollar I've never seen a dollar
nobody's got a dollar let us see the dollar oh
that's one of the producers a whole dollar Alex
suus I believe his name is the guy said I've never
seen a dollar how fast can this thing go you can
play double or triple speeds but that's for the
experts as fast as you can whoa oh my God damn
whoa no congratulations you're a winner I just
meant her skills I don't approve I just meant the
skills not the actual game itself I don't condone
I just me how good she was there it is it's
beautiful wow Andrew just playing with you I know
I know a man whose girlfriend does his shooting
for him isn't that a fine how do you [Applause]
do how how is that funny why why is what's funny
about that how do you do is a greeting why is that
funny you why why you laughing I don't know he was
laughing is you and McGregor ob one oh wow what a
funny he should have been like hello there never
been more serious in my life you and me pistols
you wouldn't have a prayer kiddo tomorrow 8:
a.m. that duck is so goofy looking why don't we
say a week from today I got sheap stuff I got
to do tomorrow anyway I honest I have no idea
what just happened I was I I was like out of
my body hbert did you see the look on Louisa's
face no why it's like he became a man you had
a fire in your belly for a second there pal yeah
I I don't have that side to me I honestly don't
know what just happened you got her attention
I mean you might die in a week but you got a
retention I'm sick to my stomach my stomach is
you're worked up that's what it is let's get a
drink hey it's our sweet young couple could I
interest you folks in some Wild Root cream oil
Jesus okay okay did you get jump scared too I
kind of saw it coming to be honest oh really
I've picked up on the fact that every scene ends
with a comedic bit I haven't seen enough movies
didn't know that was coming it seems like yeah
every every almost every scene ends with something
funny happening or someone dying or someone dying
which was meant to be funny hey why are you being
so nice to me you show up out of nowhere you're
this complete anomaly in my world of terribleness
out here I mean you must have a million better
things to do than this a million I just don't know
anything about you well can I ask you something
about you yeah flip the tables that's right why
do you love Louise we we did this already
classy she's fun she's insanely gorgeous hey
no look she's really pretty yes but I don't see
what else she's got going for her my impression
was that she was a little sour and self-absorbed
and like she is so much cooler than her you act
like this girl was performing some kind of a
charitable act by dating you Albert you're a
catch you've made something of yourself out here
you know a lot of people can't say that you're
a good sheep farmer I suck at sheep stop cutting
yourself down there was a sheep in house last week
wandered in there and then when I went to pick it
up somehow it had made $20 [Laughter] aim up sheep
boy oh there we go there all righty was that
someone else who shot it I just realized there
were Family Guy episodes that did you
know the Star Wars Episodes so it was
cool to see you and McGregor there cuz he's
Seth McFarland's such a huge Star Wars fan I
love those Star Wars Family Guy episodes so
good I think I saw them like once or a long
time ago they're so funny I know we have
a dangerous job to do here but I'm taking
[Music] this yeah that works that's right P
3D it's going to hit him right in the face yep
o oh Jesus just like he called out
earlier like the doctors with their weird
methods oh nice this got to be interesting for her
cuz he's the exact opposite
of her husband a good honest
man okay getting a little bit better it's
getting better slowly but surely [Music]
oh no his dad God Dam it over no more friends
all right make a fart dad you have earned one
of Anna Barn's very special super super secret
cookies wait what is this I I do I was just
thinking that the last time somebody gave me
one of these I became convinced that prairie
dogs could read my mind just dig a little bit
you can get so messed up doing that there you
go so there oh my God he's going to be so baked
oh yeah he's freaking the hell out really weird
yep sure enough is it supposed to be like this
she's got such a high tolerance for it though
you gave me the right amount right like you
don't oh my God he's paranoid he's like on a
roller coaster right now that's not stopping it
out see see bones are deep today like there's a
lot more I think my body is patting up for the
winter which is weird because it's not winter
but there's a lot just a [Laughter] lot oh my
God Anna he knows he knows he knows what we're
he knows what this is I don't want to no I
don't I don't want to join I don't want to
join that was a sweet scene I like that one I
like I like call their scenes together I think
they're they have good chemistry yeah and I
like their interactions she's got a way of
just boosting his morale and confidence I like
it supper time you lazy oh fake sleeping damn
was TW a trap ooh ooh who's lazy
now Sheriff sorry dude you were
able to survive rush hour but not this
movie wouldn't be a western without a
[Applause] [Music] dance she she is stunning
I don't know why he still got eyes for Lou
cuz he doesn't he cuz he vied himself so low
he doesn't imagine there's a possibility I
know well there we go wow I think he's uh
the tables are starting to turn oh [__]
I'm totally overdressed aren't I and the
lady at the boutique told me to buy this
and no one else is wearing this who
cares what these are allers but you
you I like your bustle by the way oh yeah
I really love that the most alluring what
and then I lifted up and I'd be like a
[__] it's a big joke I know exactly
cuz look when you lift it up there's
nothing but a metal cage under there
wow well the very least this will be a good way
to spend my last night a li right confidence do
you trust me yeah I do good you're going to
be fine wonder if she's going to help him
from somewhere thank you hey hey it's great
to be back here in old stump hey any Indians
here tonight oh God that's an interesting C
okay they're giving me the lantern enjoy the
bison and I hope you're enjoying your drinks
as much as my horse enjoyed making them for
you you men who long for love you may not have
the looks you may not have the dash go in your
[Music] foot but you need be a king to make any
maen of the name you may not have the cash but
you that girl your own you only a mustache hey
how sh out you're Wonder to get in well here
is my advice get it you can have your you
only got getting his practicing get it in
[Music] buddy
mustache
[__] you know what I would do if I
were Seth or Albert what would you do
shave his mustache in the middle
of the night M Pro strats nice
oh smart going to get him so messed up for the
next day give him the poopies so I guess it's
kind of weird knowing that a woman can
out shoot you huh um if you don't mind
my girlfriend and I are enjoying each other's
company want to know the real kicker though I
can out drink you too a man can't say no to a
challenge like that 50 cents to the winner 1 2
3 [__] don't feel bad alcohol doesn't harmonize
well with a woman's frail Constitution anyway I
guess not yes trick him by activating his ego put
fragility in defense mode you have the nicest guy
in the world throwing himself at your feet and
here you are with this complete [__] who I
go out with is my own business why don't you
mind your own [__] o you so blind eyes that
Big D they're not that big mytic Chinese like oh
God I I like how that's all she took from that
conversation how big her eyes are we'll keep us
warm though are you cold a little here no no no
it's okay no it's fine it's the manly thing to
do I just want to say thank you I could gotten
this far without you and I think I can do it h
I still feel like I don't know anything about
you I feel like every time I bring it up you
change the subject my story is a lot like yours
I suppose I hate the West just as much as you do
do you really oh I like you even more now there
is something about connecting over Mutual hatred
that's just so much deeper than mutual love it's
true right if two people hate the same things it
creates a bond it really does actually hey Bridget
Bridget yeah she knows what is this this is just
a little something to say thank you okay don't
get too excited what is it what is it what is it a
picture oh it can't be a picture that burns oh it
is a picture the guy that smiled oh was in Texas
I think he's smiling isn't that amazing I bought
that off a pedler it was coming through town last
week this is the guy I was telling you about this
guy would have had to sit there and smile for 30
sustained seconds I know I've never been happy for
30 seconds no one has is that Richard Maul I can't
tell in the picture rest in peace if it is voice
of two fa and Batman the Animan no one's ever done
anything like this for me oh come on now thank
you kiss kiss her kiss the girl a million
ways to kiss in the west Feel the Moment
yeah sure Liam n's going to be be happy about that
I'm sorry I I shouldn't have done that that was
very genuine it's fine you've just been a really
good friend to me that's all just a friend I
actually love these scenes where they're a little
more serious and a little more on the Romantic
side like those are actually my favorite scenes
same they're yeah they're really I mean the comedy
is still like I'm enjoying most of the comedy but
yeah the comed's all right but all the scenes with
them are awesome yeah oh this is my favorite
part of the movie these two good luck tomorrow
I'm going to be there good as sweet as this is I
bet it's going to end with a bit H probably but
what's the bit it's going to undercut everything
we've just done yeah there is that the [Music]
bit a genuine scene going to end
genuinely oh no damn he saw it Oh
I guess guess you could say Liam n's
eyes were there so he technically was
there what the hell it's Doc Brown he's
working on an invention electricity hello
oh they have electric I called it you're
SI oh my God I called that wow that was
just a joke I was saying too hey experiment I
swear I did not know that was there I promise
you guys I did not know wow I didn't know
either swear on everything that's awesome
I swear on I swear and everything I was just
saying that as a joke that's crazy but it did
end with a joke we did call it I promise
that was just that was a great joke that
was awesome he always smells like sheep but he
doesn't deserve to be shot Louise my decision
is final now do it I I'm really TI Louise oh my
god really telling her to do what I think he's
yeah my social sture is
significant uhoh what she gave him I had the
rungs he'll be able to show up but he might
have to go to the restroom a bunch gives
uh our boy the upper hand cuz he got the
poopies D of course of course
I think he's in the
bathroom she got messed up oh well now I
didn't think you'd show sheepy yeah listen
Foy oh no oh oh oh Lord in his
hat is crazy I think this is
worse than being shot is in front of
everyone no poop in that hat it's a
[Laughter] lie oh God oh
oh no I don't know why that I just walk if I'm
the other the third guy there I'm walking away
that's no that will never get out of
my head now I don't need to see that
I can't see that now I can't unsee that listen Foy
she's all yours you know I really do care about
you I don't know somewhere along the line I guess
I just forgot that a relationship is a two-way
street yeah buddy that part I've been reminded
recently of what it's like to have somebody care
about me yeah buddy and I like it so if you want
to spend the rest of your life with a full of
hair you know I just realized that last joke
might not have been clear I didn't mean that she
has a Harry I meant that boy has a mustache so
oh Aaron and I understood it we got it he gets
hair it's okay in her we UND we got we good goes
down there we got it Seth that was unnecessary
appreciate you SE yep right back at you buddy
Anna go get your woman she's not there hey do
you do you think you guys are going to have
at some point I don't know you do let us know cuz
maybe we can make it like you know like we can all
get in syn together Edward we are not having sex
sorry Ruth let's coming oh hate that for you buddy
now you need to char their own to help you out
with your confidence who's the man who's hooked
up with my wife to be fair to Seth McFarland
he had no idea she was married he didn't she
wouldn't she wouldn't say him a thing about her
life I think he's a guy who doesn't give a crap
right shot an old guy for lying to him twice
clearly mph gives a crap even one of my boys
saw a man kissing my wife last night rro I want
to know who it was oh man somebody's going to
get this is mine o [Music]
ran Reynolds no why it's okay he's Deadpool
he regenerates he didn't even get a line at
noon tomorrow where I start killing more
people I forgot I think he had a cameo
in Ted too it's been a long time since I
saw the first Ted but I believe he had a
cameo in the first head there's a lot of
celebrities in this movie let me know in
the comment section if I'm wrong if he
had a cameo in the first head let him
know I I'm pretty sure he did it's been
like at least 10 years since I saw that
movie oh Dam Mark Twain yeah who oh I just
realized both Liam niss and Y and McGregor are
both in this Jin and Obi-Wan yeah took me a second
to realize that you think I don't know when you're
lying oh no no no no please don't don't
kill the dog please don't shoot the dog
don't shoot the doggy please come
on clinch oh you think I'm joking
who okay okay okay okay oh say it was the
must it's Neil Patrick Harris it's Albert
Stark Oh no just lie should just
said it was Neil Patrick [Music]
Harris I've missed you baby no longer the
ride the lonely AR am man get d of the
woman he loves to soo bones oh no and we have
time to be husband and wife the proper way hey
[__] oh ass kill him oh [__] I can't leave
him like that kill him yeah why not just take
his gun and shoot him please put put in his ass
yay literally take his gun and shoot him right
now right just kill him right you're just going
to save yourself so many so much problems later
I have no idea why you would not just take
his gun and shoot him right then that's dumb
Albert and you gave away Albert's name so
you really should have shot him clinch is
going to be looking for you yeah not if
you killed him seriously I'm leaving uh
I'm going to San Francisco what I should have
done a week ago what about your D dad he's up
on the hill burying himself next to Mom damn
when did mom die I never meant to misle okay
you know what Anna don't even waste my time you
had a million opportunities to tell me another
million reference I didn't tell you because I
was trying to protect you oh [__] you were
looking out for your own self-interest and because
I liked you I never thought I'd meet someone like
you Albert somebody who hasn't killed people
that's really hard to find that's why women
are always going oh my God why are all the non-
murderers taken we were married when I was nine
nine what Jesus every girl that I ever fall in
love with ends up disappointing me you love me
oh you know what I'm over it you you can go was
I supposed to go oh hi I'm Anna I've beening a
killer since I was oh he waited a year what
a gentleman is your name even Anna or is it
something terrible like gwendaline I'm that same
girl you fell in love with I just didn't think
I deserved a good guy but you know what I do I
love you uh it's a good thing you didn't shoot
him I'm sorry we keep harping on it but it's
just there's a trail out back that leads out
to the ridge go he's going to kill Anna just go
Albert he always shoots on two so he shoots on
one you got to shoot on one or zero or one and
a half why didn't she just kill him I don't know
we'll probably get crap for talking about that
in the comments but it still makes no sense it
doesn't make any sense logically that's what you
do well no uh because Albert has to do it the the
hero I think that's why kill him cu the script
said she can't do it also because Albert has
to he ain't here clinch how did he find his
residence do they find in the phone book
or they asked around I guess yeah that that
makes more sense St Tony I know you're here
who oh he's hiding amongst the Sheep yep
that's smart must be stinky in there a
sheep pretty sure we haven't seen West study
yet I got to imagine there's going to be some
Indians that help out in some way sagot
from Native Americans Andrew sorry Native
Americans I got it it the red rocket I don't
need it I don't want it in my face no thank
you I got to imagine that's what's going
to happen because we have not seen him at
[Music] all
rad Stark [Music] ride it's actually pretty well
shot that's definitely Seth McFarland in the far
away shots 100% the wi shots yep not a sun double
[Music] whatsoever
keep riding don't stop I would ride to the
side next to the train that was smart that' be
smart or do that or get in the train how how the
hell what the hell do we do now how do you get the
horse and you in there let's not ask questions I
think this is when he sees the Native Americans
he comes back and has them help him against
clench when we get out of this this I'm going
to get you some horse sound good get you whatever
you want can get you a cow if you want one of
those how the do you make a fire yeah hello are
you sure you want to do this yes I'm absolutely
sure wow I I can't believe we're actually going
to have so just changed your mind with no in
town we could all by tomorrow that's a good point
okay okay all right I thought they were playing
twister what are you in pain right
now you don't like it no I love it
yeah it's just it's just it looks
like a firecracker wrapped in roast
beef okay easy now sorry okay
is that right there yeah sure
okay wrong okay I get it it's pretty
big right yeah you're huge no I meant
you who is it Anna Anna whatever your Sur name
where can I come in sure I don't even know each
other met once have they Haden together yet maybe
they had a deleted scene maybe he's coming up the
stairs please don't shoot
us on night yeah you can't
do that don't do that don't be that guy [Music]
oh I bet that smells [Music] good Sagat ah thank
you oh this is definitely giving
me some last of the Mohan vibes
what he speaks our Native American
[Music]
language pays to be a
nerd this is the way drugs lose his
[Music]
[__] he's gonna freak the
out you weren't supposed to drink the whole thing
yep oh no maybe you should have said toally
going to freak out and probably die no holy
[__] is going to go animated it's coming
I see it I see it oh when he came out of the
womb it's a boy Mr Stark all right well
don't you want to come hold the baby off
now you put that under your pillow
and the Tooth Fairy will leave you a
penny yeah come on please welcome our graduation
speaker President Abraham Lincoln whoa who's going
to play Lincoln who the hell is that Gil four
score and seven years ago oh God RP good with GF
yeah and I'm so get rich I can have all the Licor
I want I got to show my dad this scene he loves
gilberg Godfrey hey Louise Louise check out this
cool bike I got hey you want to go down to the L
[__] oh oh my God never what [__] not
again that son of a bit oh what oh wow wa
you're an idiot how can you be so blind with
eyes that big they're not that big oh The Lads
and I have prepared something special for [Music]
you may hey a mustache a mustache a mustache okay
come on is he at the Pearly Gates looks like
it what the hell trippy we are the guardians
of the future is that Patrick Stewart sounds like
it o the handle's going to bite him yep come on I
know still you can call it out but that doesn't
mean I'm ready for it you're right you're right
you're [Music] right face your fears Louis
are Anna Anna Anna of course a she's your
[Music] future
oh K the burn in the balls that's so dumb why
the why they make me laugh [__] [Laughter]
hey good that's find out if your wee
boyfriend gives a [__] about you
and let's see if he's smart
enough to shoot me like you
didn't so he's been avoiding the fight
all film now he's ready to go up against
the craziest killer in the movie l b come
and take this her don't be stupid Albert
too late for that he's already been
stupid on two you're pretty tough guy
why don't you prove it gunfight you and me
right here that's right get him on his ego
oo take out your gun the
gun with the battle wounds
on three the gun with the high XP point it at
me he should on three on one [Laughter] yeah
oh okayy look look look before you kill me
just grant me a few last words all right make
it quick let Anna live this is not her fault I
kissed her she didn't kiss me I mean she didn't
tell me she was married so it's a little bit her
fault I guess so okay maybe just shoot her in
the arm one more thing um my grandparents were
Arabic so I'm required by Muslim is he bleeding
out in the arm death chant immediately before
dying this will only take a moment poison [Music]
bullet something's wrong with him poison bullet oh
that's Baltimore oh yeah poison bullet he's
tripping out jungle light I'm far away from
over you not feeling well what's happening to
me there are A Million Ways to Die in the West
title and uh wild animals you know like snakes
you don't even have to get bitten all you need
is a little bit of the Venom introduced into your
bloodstream and you're pretty much screwed if you
drain a certain amount of Venom that's so cool
you really only need one shot now I knew my aim
wasn't good enough to hit you anywhere important
but if I caught you by surprise very smart small
amount of Venom in an open wound is enough
to kill a man if he's Albert he's dead is's
dead
oh that actually was a very smart plan well done
sheep boy hey sorry I killed your husband oh God
that was never going to work out anyway you're
not really Arabic are you no no no no oh thank
God cuz I was like a kill me I know right no
God no we're fine hey l oh she wants him again
hell no if you want to talk about things I
would like that I can come back your place
like later tonight Louise I would but I really
got to go home and work on myself throwing her
words back at her yeah damn dad's a lot of sheep
holy how you going to move anywhere way too many
sheep jeez Jesus and there's still on the roof
still one on the roof step right up folks step
right up this game again take a gander at the
shooting gallery I'll take a shot oh God no way
I've never I've never seen this movie but I know
who that is hey I like the way you die boy you
yeah that's like the perfect ending I love that
very that's awesome hey you made a Jango reference
earlier too we were able to call a couple cameos I
guess that was cool yeah I like that by the way if
you are listening to us on Apple or Spotify if
you would not mind giving us a rating we would
greatly appreciate it thank you so much um I
actually really enjoyed it if we're going to
go on the comparison of like Ted or this I mean
it's still kind of fresh but I probably go the
Ted route but I still really enjoyed this um there
was a lot of runchy Comedy obviously you're going
to expect that in a Seth McFarland thing I mean
there was a lot of the comedy I did enjoy there
was definitely some that fell flat um but the
thing I actually I mean we kind of talked about
during the reaction the thing I really liked about
it the most was the character Arc that Seth Seth
McFarland went through you know like not feeling
good enough just uh confidence and all that but
I like that you know I know it's a tropy thing
we see in movies like he needs a woman to help
bring it out of him but you know sometimes true
love does prevail and I really love that about
this film was uh or my favorite thing rather about
this film was uh the relationship and the chemist
between Seth McFarland or rather Albert and anah I
thought they had such great interactions I really
appreciated those scenes and when it actually did
get serious yes again there were some times of
levity that helped to you know break the tension
and all that but I really appreciated it when when
we were you know in those serious romantic moments
um I thought they were really good together and
I actually really thought that she was really
helping him break out of his shell like of just
like so locked in and focused on you know doing
everything to impress Louise if you will and just
like not feeling good enough in life you know and
I just I I mean that's just a good life lesson you
know um about confidence and not feeling like
you're good enough and I just I loved all those
scenes and that was my favorite part of the film
um again I like the comedy too for the most part
there were again some flat moments but overall I
I that was my favorite part what about you I will
say I I liked the movie I don't think I liked it
as much as you but I had a good time watching it
and reacting to it I think the thing that for me
that I like when movies are able to balance comedy
and drama obviously this is clearly a comedy and
this was made by Seth McFarland who is the creator
of Family Guy and with that I was not I would
to say concerned but part of me was thinking of
like okay what's this going to be like this guy
who's known for making TV a certain type of way
what's it going to be like when he transitions
over to a film and watching that seeing that
there was a lot of scenes that stopped just to
have a bit like there was a lot of like Family
Guy type cutaways not like cutaway to something
else entirely like it's like they referencing a
thing and then it cuss that thing but like things
within that scene they would cut to and pause the
momentum of it and also there was a lot of scenes
that ended with a bit sometimes just to fill that
quot but I will say this did this movie did make
me laugh a lot uh there were moments that there's
a lot of moments that were dumb but I think that
we're balanced well enough with the moments that
did work uh I will say that my favorite part of
the movie kind of what Andrew touched on was the
aspect of him and Charlie theon's character and
their chemistry those were my favorite parts of
the movie because they had really good chemistry
I like the arc that she T she brought him through
with her kind of teaching him confidence and to
believe in himself and the the nature of someone
giving themselves over to a relationship when
they're getting nothing in return I'm like that's
a very relatable thing uh that people go through
and watching him go through his individual Arc as
well as the development of their relationship was
very rewarding very satisfying I feel like okay
this man is really capable of giving us really
good dramatic genuine scenes and I would have
liked to have seen more of that Balan with the
comedy uh and not only balanced with the comedy
but I guess integrated into the comedy because
I feel like some of the best movies that are
comedies but also have those things are ones that
really mesh that together very well absolutely and
I I fully agreee with that uh also too on the flip
side I appreciated what Albert was bringing to the
table in terms of their relationship because she's
in such an abusive relationship and obviously a
forced relationship forced to marry this guy
yeah at such a young age so you know it was
nice for her character to have like meet such
a guy who's not about violence in any way and
like just loves her for who she is and I just
thought they both brought out the best in each
other and I do agree with you that I would have
like I mean well there was a lot of Comedy that
I did appreciate I did not feel it was balanced
enough for me to go oh my God over the moon yes
per Perfection which it's not an easy thing to
do you know it's not like a um you know a thing
that's uh again that I'm heavily criticizing
the point of this is such an easy uh fix it's
tough like I thought he did it well in in Ted uh
but in this I like that Back to the Future thing
sylvestri um but I feel like in this film it what
I mean cuz like you said there were a couple bits
at the end where I'm like you could see it coming
but still it just didn't even though this is again
like a runchy type of Comedy just with what we
were going with in some of these dramatic scenes
it just didn't well balance enough but having said
that I still found the film very entertaining and
enjoyable uh but and also too I actually thought
it was you know the like it actually just seeing
if there's oh oh what the somebody brand me one
of them white women I need to watch that movie so
I can understand more fantastic oh know i' I've
always I've always heard how amazing it is one
of Quint n's best yeah well I I've only seen a few
of his uh films so I definitely got to get on that
and many many other ones of his uh filmography
but um yeah know overall though I I I mean I did
appreciate and enjoy it uh like you said I I would
have liked definitely if they could have balanced
a little more of the comedy and those dramatic
scenes but these two were by far my favorite I
actually really even though he's a piece of crap
I loved Neil Patrick Harris's performance he was
fun A lot of fun he hysterical um which again
you're supposed to hate his character so from
that point of view he he you know he got business
done if you will um but uh yeah no I mean overall
fun entertaining time it was a good reaction I
feel like I don't know if I'm going to rewatch
this movie um but you know I had a fun time
watching it I had a fun time watching with you
it had its laughs uh I don't know if I'd watch it
again personally I know you guys don't want us to
give negative feedback about movies sometimes
but I got to be honest in my opinion huh they
W they want [__] on this movie no I mean it it
had it had its moments like and and again I know
it's it's supposed to be a commedy it's not
supposed to be taken literally but I'm sorry
that one moment where and again I get it he's
supposed to get the shot off of the poison which
by the way that was a well done scene by the way
with how he came up with the venomous poison in
the bullet I thought that was really I loved it
great but her having like if Seth McFarland was
going to have her knock him out and do all that
the gun shouldn't have been present or something
I don't know it just that annoyed me really
badly with like she could have easily killed
him right there like H yeah there there were a
few moments too many for me there was like huh
you get it you get the joke oh yeah yeah I had to
stop and go back and explain like the hair thing
like we we got it we're smart you don't have to
and then Seth McFarland after he made a joke he's
like explaining the joke he like did you get that
one it's like bro like it was fun good trust your
audience we understand yes also I thought it was
weird that and understand it was for the point of
comedy but how Seth McFarland's character got
to have his Arc in gaining confidence but his
friend just like is oh just like doesn't change
from start to beginning from start to finish like
she just changes her she's not a version anymore
but all of a sudden she's like okay I just changed
my mind I was like I wish we would have had done
more with that but overall if I had to rate it I'd
probably give it like a 6.57 give like a six yeah
I'll go 6.5 out of 10 go a solid six I going to
give give it a 5.5 but that feels a little harsh
so I'll go 6.5 it made me laugh so I got to give
it a six six you know I'll give it a 6.7 just for
that Doc Brown Cameo that I'm probably going to be
accused of having seen or known about but I'll
give it a 6.7.3 for docc Doc Brown J and you
McGregor and Ry Ryan Reynolds who had no lines
but it was nice to see him anyway oh my God so
many cameos I guess you could also say Lois from
Family Guy right I mean there was just Lo from
Family Guy she was there's a lot of great cameos
you got to give that the film that I mean Seth
McFarland definitely knows how to get on the phone
and say you're going to Cameo my you're going to
Cameo you too you too I mean it's got a lot of
connections got a lot of connections but you guys
do you guys have a lot of connections did you guys
like this movie let us know in the comments below
uh we had a great time watching it and hope to
see you guys pretty soon all right guys adios de
goose